Dr
drel Ben that that joke's been done
meanwhile if I made that joke I'd be
kicked off Twitter yeah see I would have
done like the Notorious K i ke there you
go uh he's he's a famous rapper called
the two
passports what about what about big
Punam oh that's a good one big Punam is
pretty that's actually real [__] deep
that's a deep guy right there I like
that
that's right all you folks been sticking
around for my hip-hop talk because after
all I am America's number one hip hop
artist they're Lil putts they said in
the chat Lil
putts dual Citizen Kane dual Citizen
Kane's Good Citizen Kane's a movie
that's not a [__]
rapper you mean dual citizen big
daddyy how about how about Outcast of
109 country
Bessie throwing the heat
today
benm
jpac again if I said any of those I'd be
throwing off the
internet they call they call Dr call
them juy ju is pretty good that's a good
one A Tribe Called
Judah Tribe Called Judah is good I was
going to say yidi mob yid mob yid mob is
good oh wow Bone Thugs and hummus okay
okay Xander uh Xander that's very funny
uh Xander and victus actually just
tweeted me
ludis ludis is good ludis is good ludis
is actually very good very good we got a
few good ones the locks and
bagels the locks and bagels is great J
Live
Crew I like that one a little more
obvious yeah yeah rund DM
circumcised 36 Million
[Laughter]
Dead hold
everybody Ghetto Boys works oh I got one
the Beasty Boys no that's already well
that's just that's they're already
they're already that I got one Rick
Reuben oh no that's not yeah how about
Rick jubin sir gri a lot they're calling
him sir grift a
lot m search they were just naming real
Jewish
people calling her DJ Jazzy Jesuit TJ
Jazzy Jess [__] fantastic it's a good
one Jack
Stark nobody is the great rapper Tunnel
Hill Gang from Papa Dan Tunnel Hill Gang
Tunnel Hill Gang I got one Palestinian
Baby
Bash that one's really good that's a
deep cut that one's really good I like
it old dirty schandra
[Laughter]
frozation Lloyd owns the
banks God damn that's very bro ever
since Frozen shaved his head ever since
a Terminator ever since Frozen shaved
his head he's been so much cooler have
you noticed that's one of those ones I'm
angry I didn't think of holy [__] that
was beautiful the banks Lloyd owns the
banks oh [__] oh
this is the become the number one artist
J rules the financial
[Laughter]
system 50%
interest in in rap a genre that I
famousy Chingy good Chingy
Ching that I've had a deep and abiding
Adoration of rap ever since I was a
youth but a youth C six
millionaire oh I was GNA say Andre 6
million okay that's also verybody Andre
6 million both very good
they run DNC they said zero Z
e800
DNC okay it's another good
one people have fire today oh man our
chat dude we have the [__] best chat
on the internet and we we've been saying
it for years but nobody is funnier than
our fans our fans are so much funnier
than us it's crazy Did anyone say Lil
wine no they L wine
good oh
[__] the doctor says I can't have Sugar
Hill
Gang it's a little wordy but that's one
of the funniest ones oh the doctor says
I can't have
suar heroic rap legends that we swall
said Holocaust exhibit
holy
[__] please tell me he spelled it eggs Z
he
did okay oh [__] oh [__] that's funny
defamation
[Laughter]
man oh [__] oh [__] he been great guys
big punitive they called them ARB choir
big punitive
how about Tyler how about Tyler the
Creator of
War Gaza
Fiasco Gaza
Fiasco uh tomrose Mercedes no torious
Pig get it cuz chewish toos proces with
another donation said Lord of the
underground of Crown
Heights uh schelly schmell and
schmendrick Lamar schri Lamar Lar is
good
mhm how about doesn't work on the
weekend doesn't work on the weekend but
spelled with the missing e yeah yeah
yeah
yeah what's kind of amazing about ghost
face would it kill you to
[Laughter]
call uh kid Keri kid Keri is good I like
that Cypress
shill cound Kodak Black
Kodak
did someone someone else donated with
smri Lamar but that was a good one thank
you uh kyli you oh KY us Rex uh U user e
grei anward said u z r e user e that's
very good uh Kyler Rex glad you liked it
vergie it wasn't Virgie it was
pessy uh less than zero Virgie isn't
even here's not here he's dead do yeah
don't even speak his name ever again
yeah uh Less Than Zero
uh Le Levan the dude uh let's see here
uh okay this is this be hard XXX tenets
getting bombed in Gaza all right okay
that was a good one that was a good how
about G easy payday loans okay I like
that uh we readed Christ Killers right
uh watch for I don't know I was making
it feels like it was an easy one that
didn't do it yet but just in case Christ
killed us in Cas someone didn't do it uh
Redbeard TM Tom McDonald is what happens
when you order your your ched Hanks from
wish my weener your face Del
slowmo uh Gates off above uh Kwa [__]
with authority there you go Tom morel's
Mercedes shabus ranks Jack cat Jesus
Christ we get it all you guys do is talk
about Owen and all those stupid
Flintstones movies I'm not going to lie
now it's da on me shabos ranks is
actually a really good one yeah yeah
good it took me a second like shabos
ranks is pretty
funny oh Irish serpant said little hat
X thank you yes sir complain a
lot okay so I'm going to read this one
they said raim raim the case pronounced
in a Jewish dialect I got it that's what
you meant right
yeah kiden play in the tunnels in St ker
posi